Nos piden dividir y simplificar
y nos dan una expresión radical
dividida entre otra expresión radical.
La clave aquí es el hecho de que
si se tiene la raíz de "x" sobre la raíz de "y",
esto es igual a la raíz,
de "x" sobre "y".
Esta propiedad se deriva
de la propiedad de los exponentes
en la cual,
si se tiene algo elevado a una potencia
y al sacar la raíz cuadrada,
estoy elevando a la potencia un medio,
dividido entre otro algo que también está elevado a la misma potencia, eso lo mismo que,
primero realizar la división
y posteriormente elevar a esa potencia.
Apliquemos eso aquí,
tenemos que esta expresión es igual a,
la raíz principal...
la raíz principal
de "60x" cuadrada "y"
dividido entre "48x".
Y voy a trabajar,
por principio de cuentas con los coeficientes
60 sobre 48,
esto lo podemos simplificar,
vamos a sacarle doceava,
vamos a dividir entre 12 estos términos,
60 entre 12 es igual a 5
y 48 entre 12 es igual a 4,
ahora, podemos dividir
el numerador y el denominador entre "x"...
"x" cuadrada entre "x"
es igual a "x",
mientras que "x" entre "x" es igual a 1.
Lo que hagamos el numerador,
hay que hacerlo en el denominador
y con eso,
ya hemos simplificado el cociente,
por lo cual nuestra expresión
quedó igual a
la raíz...
la raíz principal,
de el coeficiente, quedó como,
cinco cuartos
y de hecho esto lo podría escribir de otra manera,
pero no,
lo voy a dejar por lo pronto así.
Ya no tenemos nada en el denominador excepto ese 4
y en el numerador tenemos
"x" por "y",
por lo que esto nos queda como
la raíz de cinco cuartos "xy"
ahora, podríamos dejarlo así,
o aún podríamos sacar algo del radical .
Una posibilidad para hacer esto,
es que lo escribieras de la siguiente manera,
esto es igual a un cuarto
que multiplica por "5xy"
y todo eso por supuesto dentro del radical
y esto es lo mismo
que la raíz principal de un cuarto,
por la raíz principal de "5xy"...
para calcular la raíz principal de un cuarto,
puedes considerar que un cuarto
es igual a un medio por un medio,
o bien la expresión...
esto se puede escribir como...
o bien, podrías decir
que la raíz de un cuarto es un medio,
pues un medio por un medio
es exactamente un cuarto,
o esto lo puedes escribir como la raíz cuadrada de 1
sobre la raíz cuadrada de 4,
la raíz cuadrada de 1 es 1
y la raíz cuadrada principal de 4 es 2.
Verificamos lo que habíamos dicho,
que este término de aquí es igual a un medio
y toda la expresión resulta en un medio
que multiplica a la raíz cuadrada principal...
lo voy a poner con el mismo color...
la raíz cuadrada principal de "5xy".
Se ha simplificado totalmente la expresión,
pues ya no hay cuadrados perfectos,
así es que hemos terminado.